This video is brought to you by news voice,
the news is broken almost all of the U S media is owned by just a
handful of massive corporations. Fake news is obviously a huge problem as well.
And finding something unbiased can be really hard.
News voice is revolutionizing the news landscape.
It's an app that gives you a personalized newsfeed by aggregating major news
sites,
as well as international and independent media giving some much needed balance.
Each new story shows multiple sources,
which are all timed with their bias and perspective.
The news affects almost everything in our lives,
what we hear and what we read shapes, which people we trust, what we eat,
what we buy, how we vote,
and even how we think news voice is created by its readers. As you can,
upvote stories that you find interesting.
So more people will see them as essentially a democratized platform for news.
Plus it saves you time.
You get all the news and all the sources and one app so that you can be better
informed and it's totally free. Anyway,
get started with news voice today for free through the link below it's available
on both Google play and the Apple app store. And now let's get into the video.
[Inaudible].
It seems that anything could happen this year, 2020, for example,
50 years after the Vietnam war, the United States army is returning to Vietnam,
but instead of going to attack Vietnamese communists this time,
they're going to defend them. Check the set.
[Inaudible].
West. As Theodore Roosevelt arrives in Vietnam,
becoming second us care to visit since the 1970s stars and stripes.
The socialist Republic of Vietnam is one of the few officially communist
countries left.
And the world its flag is even red with a five pointed star in the middle and on
its Northern border is the people's Republic of China,
which is also ruled by a single party. The communist party of China.
In other words, both countries have very similar political systems.
Both countries also began implementing free market reforms. In the 1980s,
both countries are home to the factories of the world.
Those countries share a common border.
[Inaudible].
With so many things in common.
You think that China and Vietnam would be natural allies, wouldn't you? Well,
my dear friends, official politics, nothing,
nothing could be further from the truth.
[Inaudible].
Because Vietnam takes more assertive approach to the South.
China sea Beijing tries to manage tensions South China morning post.
If you have an idea and the last five years alone,
the China and Vietnam have each launched several cyber attacks.
The last one was just a few months ago.
So Vietnamese hackers stole data about COVID 19 from the Chinese government.
Meanwhile, China was responsible for sinking some Vietnamese fishing boots.
The main reason was disputes about the control of some tiny islands and the
South China sea that's right, some tiny at the end of this video,
you will understand why they are so important. And you'll say, well,
that's a very unbalanced conflict. Isn't the grant.
And there is some truth to that.
Vietnam is a country of more than 96 million people,
which has been growing at almost an average rate of 7% for 10 years. However,
these numbers pale in comparison to the more than 1 billion people in
China, As example,
the Chinese Navy has 59 submarines and 59 frigates.
The Vietnamese Navy has eight submarines and four frigates.
So what's the superpower propping up Vietnam. Well,
it's none other than uncle Sam.
And the question is why is there so much tension between Vietnam and China?
What is happening in the South China sea?
And how is it possible that United States,
which was Vietnam's worst enemy is becoming its best ally today.
We will answer all these questions, but first as always,
let's take a look at some history.
Comrades of convenience and.
54 Vietnam became independent from not Britain as is usually the case,
but France until then Vietnam, Laos,
and Cambodia had all been part of what was going on.
Then as French and or China after the Indochino war,
Vietnam was divided into two hubs, San Familia,
the communist North and the South,
which was an ally of the United States as it happened in the Korean peninsula,
a completely arbitrary dividing lane was used in this case. The 17th parallel,
as you can probably imagine,
the Northern communists led by who had the support of mouse, China,
and that support continued during the Vietnam war.
The one that we all know about the one where the North and South of Vietnam
fought for total control of the country for a whopping 20 years,
As you knew,
the United States supported the South and China supported the North without a
second thought to give you a rough idea over the course of the entire war.
China sent the communists in Vietnam, 560 tanks,
164 fighter planes and 1,922,000 pixels.
But none of this will surprise you. Well,
it is logical that communist country like the people's Republic of China
supported the Vietcong.
And it would be logical to think that after the victory of communism in Vietnam,
China would become an ally of this country.
What should have been an unbreakable Alliance was cut short by this man.
Better to kill an innocent by mistake than spare an enemy by mistake, whole pot,
Cambodian dictator.
Who you just saw on your screen as pulled pot.
The man who ordered the greatest gen site and history and knew I am not
exaggerating even a little bit POL pot established a communist dictatorship in
Cambodia in 1976, the Camaro Rouge.
[Inaudible].
Mayor Cruz believed that the only way to end capitalism was by eliminating all
of its institutions and the people who worked in them only in this way,
could a collectivist society be built from scratch.
Something like wiping the whole country and starting again. For example,
skilled teachers were accused of being intellectuals who perpetuated
individualistic ideas.
So the camera Rouge didn't hesitate and executing all of them.
And we're not just talking about teachers, businessmen, lawyers,
and fair title women, sec people,
basically everyone who was not useful for the society that POL pot wanted to
build was executed.
[Inaudible].
In total,
the Cambodian genocide wiped out almost 25% of the
population, but take a deep breath. Let's get back to our story.
As you can imagine, China had also supported the Camaro Rouge in Cambodia.
And at first the Camaro Rouge also supported the Viet Cong.
They were all communists comrades fighting together against the oppressors of
the waist. However,
have you think that having ideology in common is enough to form a lasting
relationship, then boy or boy are you wrong?
The moment the United States left the region,
Paul part began to mistrust the Vietnamese.
The Camaro Rouge wanted a communist Cambodia, but in their own way,
they didn't want Vietnam,
which is a much larger country to get involved in their affairs pool pump began
by purchasing all of the Camaro Rouge who had been drained in Vietnam and for
such a fanatical man executing thousands of fellow party members was not
Cambodian.
Camaro's engaged in a series of skirmishes on the border with the Vietnamese.
So.
What did Vietnam do? Well in 1978,
Vietnam invaded Cambodia and drove out to the Camaro Rouge.
And this is where we have to take a step back to break down the partnerships we
have in play here. Let's give you some background.
Vietnam was an ally of the Soviet union.
But China.
Was moving away from the Kremlin because they wanted to maintain their
sovereignty. At the same time,
China was supporting Cambodia and beginning to establish diplomatic relations
with the United States.
Oh.
In other words,
China could no longer allow Vietnam to invade Cambodia because Cambodia was
its ally. So in 1979,
China started a war with Vietnam from 1954 to 1979.
Vietnam was constantly at war first with the French then with the United States,
then with Cambodia and finally with China. In fact,
it was precisely in these years that the gap between Marxists Lenise and Maoists
was occurring all over the world. That is on the one hand,
there were communist parties that remained faithful to the USSR and other
communist parties that defended the interests of China. To give you an idea.
The directors of the Chinese communist party were into various languages from
English to Spanish and sent to the Maoist parties of all countries around the
globe.
And this way the militants knew what Beijing's possession was at any given
moment,
Example their attitude to Vietnam,
the Sino Vietnamese war left more than 60,000 dead on both sides and both
China and the United States put all kinds of trade sanctions on Vietnam.
Meanwhile, Vietnam continued to invade Cambodia as an example,
in 1986, every Cambodian minister had a Vietnamese advisor at his or her saints.
And a third of Vietnamese military spending was going on maintaining the
occupation of Cambodia. In other words,
if you think that only European countries are created colonies,
then you are wrong. Although let's be fair.
It is true that the Vietnamese army did dispose of the regime responsible for
the greatest GeneSight in history.
Whereas when Europe came knocking and other places,
usually that was the other way around the largest genocide, of course,
in terms of the population of their country, but don't think for a second,
but they brought freedom and democracy with them indeed until the mid 1980s,
the Vietnamese government followed Marxism Leninism to his protectable final
consequences. And the Vietnamese economy was.
The lumps.
All that changed in 1986 that year,
the more moderate factions of Vietnamese communism took power.
And that's how the policy of the DOI, again,
which we covered in another video basically [inaudible] was a program of free
market reforms, similar to what Shayna was also doing at the table.
In addition to freeing up his economy,
Vietnam focused on improving its relations with the rest of the world.
All of this explains why in 1989, Vietnam pooled out of Cambodia,
gradually relations with China, improved in both Beijing and Hanoi.
They focused on economic growth and trade.
And so they continued for decades collaborating on projects.
This one
cross border highway linking China in Vietnam concludes trial run trynna daily.
That new story is from 2018. We're talking about highway that connects Hanoi,
the capital of Vietnam with Kunming, which is a Southern Chinese city.
At the time. This highway was a symbol of reconciliation. Finally,
these two countries,
which destiny was calling to understand each other were United by common route.
And you're probably thinking, well, problem solved there.
Where is this conflict now? Well, let's take a look at that right now.
Contentious islands.
Pay attention to this map here. We can see the South China sea.
Beautiful.
So far.
It seems pretty clear where each country's territorial waters reach the rest
would be considered international waters, right?
Well, you are wrong. If we zoom in, we find a lot of tiny islands.
It looks a little bit like God sneezed on the map. Well,
these islands are the Spratley and parasail Island.
Actually.
Generally speaking, we couldn't even call them islands as such,
but as coral atolls and a tall is a ring shaped Island formed by you guessed it
coral. If you look closely at the photos,
you will see that the 130 coral a tools of the parcel islands have barely any
surface areas.
An idea.
The combined land territory of these islands is just 7.75 kilometers squared.
And the highest point is 14.
Meters. Many of them.
Couldn't even be walked on. However,
technically they are territories and therefore susceptible to belonging to one
country or another until 1932, it was assumed that they belonged to China.
Then they became part of French Indochina later,
Japan invaded them and know their ownership is in dispute with China and
neighboring countries. And I know at this point what you're probably thinking,
but who cares about coral atolls? I mean, apart from fish,
obviously who's going to fight or something like that.
But the truth is that they matter a lot.
[Inaudible].
First of all, there are no oil and gas deposits in the area. Therefore,
if these atolls are part of a country's territory,
that country can extract the oil in surrounding waters without any problem,
after all the oil is within their territorial waters,
but we're not just talking about oil. Think about it.
These islands are the perfect place to Poot military basis.
Have Shana took over the power of sale.
Islands could set up military ports to control all of the trades and the area.
Roughly one third of all international trade is concentrated in Southeast Asia.
It is one of the most booming areas in the world.
All those ships loaded with Apple AirPods, Samsung mobiles,
and so many other products made in Vietnam have to pass through here.
But if China had a rule of military bases at the Gates of Vietnam,
it could block all exports and the blink.
Aye.
Vietnam has brought to late laws that say these islands belong to them.
China has done the same and since no country recognizes the other's laws as the
actions that matters. And that's why news Lincoln. This is so weird.
Try not to build school and contested Paracel islands, BBC
China's showcases jet fighters at South China, sea islands, global times.
At this point, I know what you're thinking. Hey, did they build those things?
Didn't we say just a second ago,
that these are coral atolls where there's hardly any from surface. Well,
what the Chinese have done is start building artificial islands. For example,
one of these atolls is the so-called ferry cross reef. And this case,
the satellite image shows how China has been covering the space in the center
with sand brought in by ships.
And a few years I.
Told us the only had a large Lake in the center of being turned into small
islands, islands that in some cases have been converted into missile silos.
According to many analysts,
it is almost impossible for China to build a large military base in the area,
the small land area and claim it,
make it virtually impossible to install large missile systems or military ports,
even SU and Vietnam. They are real.
Scared.
Breaks up. anti-China protests, UBC.
As you can imagine, these protests were not spontaneous.
They're supported by the Vietnamese government itself,
but don't think that this is all a political.
[Inaudible].
Mr. Xi Jinping and his Vietnamese counterpart yang food Trung do not get along,
but many Vietnamese fishermen have been attacked by Chinese bulls. In fact,
in 2020 China even sunk a fishing boat in the parasail islands.
And we are not just talking about skirmishes.
Chinese hackers have attacked the computer systems of the Vietnamese government
and with the Corona virus crisis,
Vietnamese hackers did the same with China and this case,
they wanted to get data on the pandemic.
But as you might have figured out by now, no matter how many hackers Hanoi has,
they cannot compete with the hackers in Beijing.
And that is why Vietnam is also leading the conflict by more civilized methods.
Check this out. [inaudible].
Non threatens China with litigation over the South China sea Lawfare.
You can probably imagine what they're thinking about this in China. Oh no.
I'm so scared. Vietnam has reported those. We'll have to find a lawyer.
Maybe we should stop building artificial islands. We might get a fame.
And it's this point that the game of alliances changes again,
pay attention here, because this is when it all starts happening.
The American friend.
And the year 2000 Vietnam and the United States signed a trade agreement.
After decades of amnesty, these two countries were back on good terms.
20 years later,
Apple is already manufacturing its airports and Vietnamese factories and
thousands of Americans make business trips to set these like Hanoi or who G-Man
city among others, this particular American citizen,
whose name I'm sure you all.
Nope.
Trump says second summit with North Korea.
Kim Jong UHIN will be in HANA and BC news.
The fact that Vietnam was chosen as the setting for this summit is no
coincidence. And it's four years in office.
Donald Trump has visited Vietnam twice and the Vietnamese diaspora loves
Donald Trump to give you an idea. In 2016,
the Pew research center carried out a survey in different countries asking about
citizens' perception of capitalism. According to this survey,
the most pro capitalist country in the world is Vietnam.
According to this study,
the Vietnamese are more pro capitalist than the Americans themselves,
but we are not only talking about ideology here too. There are concrete.
Actions.
Aircraft carrier Roosevelt,
we'll Vietnam this week USNI news from July, 2020.
The second time in two years that an American aircraft carrier has docked in a
Vietnamese port. And this is striking because before 2018,
the last time a us aircraft carrier passed through the area was in the 1970s.
So what is going on? Well,
the reasons behind the United States sending aircraft carriers to Vietnam should
be very clear. They are supporting Vietnam in the face.
Of China's expansion
[inaudible].
And as you can probably imagine,
Beijing has not been standing ably by just this summer.
The Chinese army conducted Naval exercises.
In the area.
[inaudible].
No mistake. This is not just a fate between Vietnam and China.
There are many countries that are getting seriously frightened by the
expansionism of Beijing, from Japan to India, to Taiwan. However,
Vietnam could be a strategic ally for the United States. First,
they are perfectly positioned to be able to install military bases and with
which to control the area. In addition,
Vietnam is one of the big winners of the Corona virus, economic crisis.
They have managed their virus response in such a way that it is hardly affected
them at all. At the time of making this video,
only 35 people had died and only 1000.
They've been infected.
Clearly.
They could be a valuable ally and the trade war with China,
but these are all topics for other videos. Now, as always,
the questions are over to you. Well,
we see an open war between China and Vietnam.
Do you think that U S support for Vietnam could result in the country having a
democracy? You can leave your answers in the comments below. And of course,
don't forget that here at visual politic, we release new videos every week.
So subscribe to this channel, if you haven't done so already.
And if you haven't, why not and hit the bell down there.
So you don't miss any of our other updates. If you liked this video,
please give us a link and we'll see you in the next one.
Did he use it.